what is the best moment in one piece is
it Robin's desperate I want to live and
does that moment rank above or below
when Luffy absolutely destroyed this
Celestial Dragon or could both of these
moments even fall behind at this island
shaking clash between Whitebeard and
Roger let's find out as I take on the
impossible challenge of ranking the 23
best moments in all of One Piece
starting with the moment that literally
saved sanji's life because in Chapter 58
Sanji and his mentor zeph were stranded
on this deserted island here now at this
time the aspiring cook hated this old
man because zev's crew basically killed
sanji's former crewmates 70 days later
Sanji is starving and about to die so he
plans to steal zeph's remaining food
however he quickly learns that all zeph
has actually left is treasure and then
he is stunned when he sees this this
honestly quite gruesome scene makes
Sanji cry like a little baby and he
realizes that zeph has literally cut off
and eaten his own leg just so Sanji
could have more food to eat himself and
while this might seem like an unexpected
moment to pick for this list just wait
until you see uh which shocking moments
I ranked inside my top three however a
person eating himself for the sake of a
little boy is really only the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to the straw Hat's
heartbreaking backstories and this is
absolutely true as well for Brooke's
flashback which let me tell you this
moment absolutely ruined me you might
remember that his crew is literally
dying from a deadly poison here and the
music loving crew joins together in one
last tear-jerking Encore and as Brooke's
crewmates drop one by one I was
literally bawling my eyes out because
what a sad but also incredibly powerful
moments and honestly that's really a
strength of one piece that it can make
you feel both stuff like this really
pure sadness but also absolute joy and
no scene captures the joy of the story
as much I think as as this epic panel
right here and that's because we've just
witnessed the former pirate King's epic
journey to reach the end of the grand
line and as we are all on the edge of
our seats wondering if we will see what
the one piece treasure actually is we
only get to see their legendary reaction
to it which is everybody laughs and not
just any laugh like being sarcastic
about it no a true feeling of absolute
Joy here which only makes me even more
Curious really what this treasure really
is and if this moment is only at number
21 then just wait until you see what's
coming up next because here we have one
of the most jaw-dropping moments in the
entire story now at this point Luffy has
battled his way through hundreds of
enemies of Venus lobby as he tries to
rescue Robin and everything was going
pretty smoothly honestly until he was
stopped by this guy and you have to
remember that this government secret
agent here was basically Untouchable at
this point in the story until Luffy
revealed this wow this absolutely blew
my mind I mean for the first time in the
story Luffy showed an actual power up
and he immediately demolished the world
government agent with his new
supercharged speed and strength and
while Gear 2 was an incredibly hype
moment in Luffy's Journey perhaps no
event was more important to him than the
next one and that's because all the way
back in chapter 1 Shanks gave Luffy his
famous straw hat which inspired him of
course to become a great pirate and it's
a simple moment that I think a lot of us
take for granted but without it Luffy
literally may never have gotten as far
as he has in the story in the first
place but of course we absolutely cannot
talk about inspiration without
remembering this man's epic finale
because in this climactic moment of Dr
herlook's life I was completely torn up
inside young Chopper here had mistakenly
made a deadly soup which was eaten by
his only friend in life and I mean how
tragic think is that but instead of
making Chopper feel guilty for basically
killing him you'd look instead
confronted the evil ruler of the island
and delivered the most epic speech maybe
in the entire story and then of course
he even did this and uh wow even just
reliving it right now it's just
heartbreaking in so many ways I mean for
Chopper to lose the only person who
really cared about him and for myself to
just see how far this man would actually
go to care for his adoptive son all
right I'm not crying it's just a little
water on the camera however that moment
isn't even close honestly to the best
moment that we'll discuss later on but
first we have a scene that shows Luffy's
incredible faith in his crew I'm talking
about when Sanji here abandoned the crew
to go to whole cake Island and Luffy
said uh-uh I'm not losing my favorite
cook and he chased him down and finally
caught up to him on whole cake Island
right here Sanji though at this point
genuinely thought that he was doing what
was best for the crew and tried to trick
Luffy into leaving by making him hate
him even going as far as to beat his
captain like he was tenderizing a chunk
of meat oh my God like this moment made
me so mad that Sanji would go this far
on the one hand but also feel so sad for
him because he felt like that was his
only Resort of getting Nami and Luffy
away I mean yeah Nami hit him again but
of course even after getting this
beating Luffy saw right through his
intentions and continued to believe in
Sanji and eventually brought him back to
the crew which just goes to show just
how much Luffy really loves and cares
for them and now while this moment might
have threatened to break the bonds of
the straw hat crew this next moment
literally shook the world to its core
and that's because in Marine Ford we
experienced the heartbreaking loss of
Luffy's brother here and honestly I
never for a single moment actually
believed that we would lose both Ace and
the World's Strongest Man Whitebeard as
well but after tanking hundreds of
bullets cannonballs sword attacks and
even having half of his face blown off
like here in the manga white beard still
stood tall and proclaimed that the one
piece is real now this moment not only
became one of the most iconic sentences
in all of One Piece but it made me
really shiver with its epicness and it
reminded us that Luffy at this point
still had a very very long way to go to
reach his goals however from this very
epic but nonetheless sad scene we now
shift to what is maybe the greatest
adrenaline rush in the entire story so
far because we're here in sabaori
Luffy's friend has just been shot by
this world Noble and Luffy is pissed he
walks towards the Celestial Dragon
dodging bullets left and right without
carrying and absolutely smashes this guy
into the next Dimension and we like
really hated this guy so it was just so
satisfying to see him being crushed like
that but now before you go out and punch
your most hated enemy instead why not
smash that subscribe button instead for
more one-piece content like this and
anyways has your favorite moment shown
up in the ranking yet because if not it
might just be up ahead because this next
moment and character is certainly one
that I will never forget and might be a
top Contender for many of you and that's
because there is almost no character we
fell in love with faster than Corazon
here because after just a few chapters
of absolutely despising him for kicking
law to loving him for taking care of the
sick and dying young doctor and again
the moment I just couldn't help but bawl
my eyes out once again was when he let
himself be killed just to give law a
chance to live and he even stayed alive
long enough fighting his wounds to hide
lost heartbreaking cries and uh well
this was one of the most impactful
deaths in the entire story it was not as
incredible I would say as at this moment
right here and that's because after Zoro
was sliced up like a cucumber he holds
up his sword and shouts that he will
never lose again pledging his allegiance
to Luffy and at the same same time he
doubled down on his loyalty and the crew
and man I just love Zorro but while this
moment showed Zoro just how far he still
has to go this next moment showed the
Luffy that he was nowhere near strong
enough to fulfill his dreams and that's
because in Marine for it after he had
struggled and gone through so much to
save his brother they could almost taste
Freedom until this of course happened
and let me tell you when I saw this for
the very first time in the anime it was
like I had my own massive hole in my
chest I was genuinely shocked and in
physical pain for this and as Luffy was
holding his dying brother in his arms it
literally broke his mind and really it
broke me too it just shows that the
deeper the bonds of Brotherhood the more
heartbreaking it is when those bonds are
then broken and what a fantastic
unexpected moment in the story which is
exactly the same heartbreak I actually
felt during this next moment that's
because when Luffy decided the crew
needed a new ship he his best friend
Usopp felt massively betrayed you see
usop and the ship were so connected that
it felt like Luffy was choosing to get
rid of Usopp as well and the argument
got so heated that the two eventually
had to square off in a duel and really
this was just so hard to watch like and
I mean despite Uso really pulling every
trick that he has I feel all along that
he stood absolutely no chance of beating
Luffy and our favorite sniper
temporarily left the crew and gosh this
was tough kind of like having to say
goodbye to a favorite pet I guess which
admittedly is absolutely insane that
this moment did make the top 10 but just
wait until you see the legendary and
actually surprising I like to think
moments that are coming up at the end of
this video kicking it off with one of
the coolest scenes in the entire story
and honestly I don't think there has
ever been a scene that has better
captured the themes of the story of One
Piece better than this legendary moment
right here people's dreams never die
which is true even in death and there is
is one death in particular that impacted
all of the straw hats more than any
other you know which one I'm talking
about but it's of course the funeral of
the going Mary and boy did I never
expect to cry over a ship in my life but
that's exactly what happens when the
crew put their first vessel to rest and
it was truly a true friend and crewmate
was lost that day but of course never
forgotten and however this moment I
think was nowhere near still as shocking
as this next one and let me tell you
that after all the death and destruction
that took place on the back of this
giant elephant I never expected the
animal Mings were actually protecting
this Samurai all that time but when they
said ryzo is alive I literally just had
to sit and stare because my brain could
not really process what I was witnessing
here I mean dude this cat and dog
sacrificed a literal arm in the leg plus
their whole country was almost wiped out
and I truly thought that Riser was not
here so this moment hit me like almost
no other one in the entire story and
like I know that friendship is kind of a
meme in anime but there has never been a
display of loyalty more powerful than
this one I think I mean just actually
let me let me take that back because
this next one here now to think about it
is actually also got tier levels of
loyalty and that's because this Sam
right here survived an entire hour of
Torment in a ridiculously hot pot of
boiling oil while literally carrying his
entire crew on his back I mean how heavy
on the symbolism do you want to go and
to top it all off Odin died with a smile
showing us that this was truly a man who
gave everything of himself to protect
his friends family and Country and while
we all knew that Odin's death was coming
I don't think anyone expected just how
heroic this would turn out to be what a
true chat but an even more unexpected
twist came way earlier in the store
story in chapter 216 where VV made the
shocking choice to not join the crew and
all right let me tell you there has not
been a single character in the entire
story that the fan base probably wanted
more desperately to rejoin with the crew
like people really love Vivi I mean she
did travel with the straws for a really
long time but in the end she left us
kind of blue balled with this heartfelt
speech and the legendary scene where
they all show off their exes maybe for
nakama again hopefully very soon oh
actually also let me show you something
I do think I've made a short about this
but I actually have this uh this really
cool traditional Japanese ukioi print of
just that moment which I'm really proud
of it's really cool just wanted to show
that off quickly on to the next moments
because while Vivi chose to stay behind
when another character finally joined
the crew it made one of the most
emotional moments in the story and in my
opinion it is the first truly gut
punching scene in the entire story in
the first place you know what I'm
talking about because for over 70
chapters Nami was smart strong-willed
and didn't let anyone boss her around
but that all changed during our Long
Park in chapter 81 Nami has just lost
everything years of hard work to collect
treasure to free her Village had just
been stolen in an instant and she was
powerless stopping the villagers to go
and March towards arlong Park where they
would surely be killed and so honestly
when she finally broke down and cried
out to Luffy for help it made me want to
suit up and go fight Arlo myself
honestly man uh going through all of
these moments is kind of like a real
roller coaster over here but we still
have the most impactful moments still to
come because at number four is the
moment that changed the entire final
Saga of the story and come on you know
this was gonna be in the top five
because in chapter
1044 of the manga we have the Awakening
of gear 5 Luffy and let me just say that
this moment God my heart pounding like
almost no other and it did break the
entire one piece fan base just like
everyone else I had waited for years for
Luffy's gear 5 transformation but I
could have never imagined that it would
turn out like this and I love it what a
crazy twist with a devil fruit and it
was perfectly on brand for Luffy and
even though I have so many questions
about this power this moment combines
some of the pre-time skip wackiness with
insanely cool new powers for a truly
legendary and Unforgettable moment in
the story though even gear 5 did
honestly not make me jump out of my seat
like this next one and that's because
I've never been more surprised at a
single moment in one piece than when
Charlotte katakuri decided to stab
himself during his fight with Luffy and
yeah you may be surprised that this
moment is ranked so high here but to me
really it was just so completely
unexpected and such a cool cool unique
pure moment and I will never forget the
absolute mind-boggling shock of that
moment when I first read it because
after Luffy was tricked and nearly
knocked out by katakuri's Sister the
Mochi man who had made fun of Luffy the
entire time could have easily finished a
fight here but instead he chose to even
the playing field by literally stabbing
a hole through his stomach at the same
point no other villain in the story has
ever done that and it is just one of the
reasons that katakuri at this moment is
an absolute fan favorite especially for
me personally and the number two most
insanely impactful moment is likely many
people's favorite scene a moment of such
excitement relief and pure desperation
which is when Robin finally told the
crew I want to live and even though
Robin betrayed the crew and nearly got
them killed they never gave up on her
they chased her across two islands beat
up some of the most powerful secret
agents of the world government and even
declared war on the government itself to
to show her that nothing could stand in
the way of saving her life which now of
course you will know means that at
number one is the most legendary Epic
absolutely pure moment of insane
greatness in the story which is of
course nothing happens and honestly what
more do I need to say I mean zaro is
just the peak of awesome and nothing
surpasses this moment in the story for
me but this moment might also have been
real foreshadowing for Zorro's ultimate
power up later on in the story because
his unbreakable will is what led him to
eventually unlock Congress haki during
his fight with this Godlike figure right
here and this was such a legendary
moment that I of course had to include
it in my ranking of the top conquer
hockey moments in the story as well
which you can watch right here I'm sure
it'll contain a lot of moments you've
missed from this video on purpose and so
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next